To give you an idea of what Salesforce is, we talked to a developer who
told us how he became a Salesforce developer, and how he uses it every day.
>> I'm David Liu. I'm a Salesforce developer at Google, and
I dream in Salesforce. I graduated school with a marketing degree.
didn't know how to write a single line of code. But marketing always
works with sales, and that's how I got started with Salesforce. And just due
to you know, circumstances on the job, I dabbled a little in code
and, and I fell in love. It was, it was love at first sight.
and, and from there you know, I just went All the
way forward with it, and you know I told myself, wow I
love this so much. You know in, in 20 years time if
I looked back at my life and, and I didn't know how
to code, then you know, I'd be really disappointed in myself.
So so I picked up Sales First Coding and, and yeah, now
I'm doing what I love. Salesforce, it's really like a, like a
playground. You can build anything you want with it, like I've seen
people build apps for recruiting I've seen people build video
games on Salesforce, you can build websites. it's really up
to your imagination what Salesforce is. There's a lot of
things you don't have to worry about when you're coding
in Salesforce. When you're coding in other languages, there's these
thing call boilerplate code. Just code that you have to
write thats thats meaningless, that's totally unreadable. That you have
to write just so that your code works. In sales force,
every line of code you write is is directly relevant to
your app. It's all business logic So there's two ways you
can build things in sales force. You can do the point
and click way, Or you can code, and, and most of the
time, you're actually doing a little bit of both. I started
with point and click. started not knowing anything about coding whatsoever.
The skills that you learn when you're doing point and click,
it's absolutely super important for coding. you cannot be a good Salesforce
developer without knowing the point and click stuff really well.
the reason for that is, there's so much you can do
with point and click. if you can do it without
code you always want to do it without code. One really cool
thing about Salesforce is how quickly you can become good
on the platform. How quickly you can become a good developer
from not knowing how to code a single line in six
months time you can probably learn enough to get a job
as a sales force developer. I love Sales Force, yes.
[LAUGH]